ist Deutschland aus italienischer Sicht
noch diesbezüglich ein verlässlicher
Partner schönen Dank für die Frage zur
deutschen
haushalspolitik ein verlässlicher
Partner ist de nur zuverlässig ist seine
Mutter noch zuverlässig meine fresse ich
kann es nicht mehr hören dieses Genörgel
wir haben die 60 Milliarden Euro die für
die coronakrise gedacht waren jetzt für
andere Sachen ausgegeben die fehlen
jetzt weil das Bundesverfassungsgericht
gesagt hat Pui dürft ihr nicht darf ich
nicht ich bin der fucking Bundeskanzler
ich darf alles hier man kann mir doch
nicht 5 € geben dann sagen aber nicht
für Alkohol ausgeben wenn ich will gehe
ich Dienstag morgen in die Tanke und hol
bakard Cola jetzt fragen wir mal alle
Olaf wie geht das das 60 Milliarden Euro
fehlt anstatt mal zu fragen Olaf wie
geht's dir eigentlich damit schlecht
geht na ja wir haben auf jeden Fall
schon eine Idee wie wir das Geld wieder
reinholen Christian Lindner und ich
machen eine Benefizveranstaltung und
sammeln Geld für Deutschland jeder Euro
zählt der Slogan frag nicht was deine
Regierung für eine Scheiße gebaut hat
sondern wie du ihr da wieder raushelfen
kannst keine weiteren Fragen